où
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue dans une
leçon spéciale mat du couloir
aujourd'hui et que j'ai envie que mon
oncle mon geste et femmes alors le mag
du couloir c'est quoi qu'est-ce que
c'est pourquoi il ya des couleurs dans
les échecs on lui met des couloirs il ya
des couloirs il y avait il ya des
rangées donc un couloir donc c'est tout
simplement passer un couloir c'est comme
c'est une grande allée à peu fermé voilà
donc le glas du coup voir c'est quoi
c'est comme la vache kédougou work il
faut vous tirent dessus c'est ça qu'il
faut pas la rater
évidemment que c'est un petit peu la
même chose donc sauf que la vache c'est
sarrois c'est le roi de perse
il faut pas louper donc en général c'est
pas quelque chose de trop compliqué à
trouver mais on va voir quand quelques
subtilités qui font que ce match qui est
comme un des matchs les plus
élémentaires aux échecs avec une des
tactiques les plus les plus amusantes
aux échecs peut parfois être un petit
peu plus compliqué et faire plaisir
comme des grands champions aux échecs ou
d'accord donc on va voir tout de suite
un exemple de ce que c'est que le mc du
couloir donc leçon tactique aujourd'hui
donc une leçon qui se dédient évidemment
plutôt réalisons on va dire bonjour
amateurs ou qu'ils découvrent au jeu
d'échecs joueurs expérimentés journaux
club de laon connais ce match mais c'est
pas c'est pas tout
forcément mauvais de revoir les maths
alimentaires parfois ça remet les idées
en place
et puis bon là on peut pour cette leçon
spéciale technique je vais décliner donc
cet exemple de manière assez assez
original et et passent pas toujours si
simple que ça quand même assez
intéressante pour pour faire fonctionner
les méninges des téléspectateurs donc là
le maître du gloire donc c'est un match
qui se fait presque exclusivement avec
la tour qui peut également se faire avec
la dame aussi donc c'est un maître qui
se fait avec des pièces dites lourdes la
dame et la tour sont appelés des pièces
lourdes donc là j'ai placé donc deux
tours sur la position pour montrer que à
qu'on peut faire le match de coupe le
maître du couloir mais que l'autre camp
ne peut pas le faire voilà d'accord
alors pour cette position le bon coup
donc le bon coup pour pour les blancs
avant de le dire surtout vous montrer ce
que c'est ak couloir là on voit à roy
noir qui est prise signé donc de
derrière ses pions ce qui veut dire que
toute cette rangée
on dira que le droit ne peut pas quitter
cette frange de paris qui a quitté cette
rangée donc il faudrait tout simplement
placer la tour donc la tour qui clignote
là actuellement pour rien a placé donc
sur cette rangée pour mater l'on a tout
simplement puisque voilà il serait un
échec sur toute la colonne il se rue
mathe donc le coin sable par exemple le
coût est simple il faut jouer autour des
huit échecs mais je dis je dis pas mal
non là c'est pas mal c'est pas encore
matt mais ça va l'être et ça va être
plus que jamais des couloirs latour
adverse doit défendre le seul coup c'est
le seul courrier le roi ne peut pas fuir
puisqu'il est dans un couloir
donc on me l'a toujours là et après on
prend un tour et l'a donc ses échecs et
mat
voilà la position donc élémentaires du
maître de couloir voilà la position
effectivement avec la tour qui contrôle
ici toute la traverse le bois ici qui
conseille peut pas peut pas s'échapper
c'est impossible donc ouais c'est ça
c'est le mec le plus simple facile à
retenir
on peut noter que si par exemple les
blancs se trompe et moins que le retour
de deux cases par contre on pour m
demander pourquoi les noirs ne peuvent
pas faire échec et mat en mettant la
tour sur ses seins
oui pourquoi voilà donc une bonne
question
et bien tout simplement parce que là
dans ces cas là il ne peut pas parler de
couloir puisque le roi adverse peut fuir
on voit que le roi en ga à une tests de
fuite effectivement voilà faire deux
matches deux passes de suite
donc c'est vrai que bon bout là d'où
cette idée souvent dans les partis en
milieu de partie qu'il faut quand on
sait pas trop quoi faire il est souvent
utile de créer une petite fenêtre pour
le rock
donc là on est en poussant le évidemment
c'est toujours utile de créer une
fenêtre dans cette position la fenêtre
qui n'a pas été créée ça aurait été bien
de le faire en jouant en jouant au
préalable en poussant ce petit pion l'a6
en poussant alors on fait souvent les
fenêtres soient effectivement en jouant
ce genre de coup ci soit et dans tout le
monde j'ai six en tout cas faut créer
une ouverture pour le roi il faut la
fenêtre avec la la la petite fenêtre
fait avec le pion à h 1 h 6 est plus
fréquent qu on va dire que cette fleur
est là et fait automatiquement souvent
quand il ya un fou qui vient en fait
mais tout à fait voilà donc là on en
sait plus sur la position de base du bas
du couloir
maintenant on va passer à des exercices
très amusant alors donc premier avec des
expériences dans cette première position
on a quand même une partie de champion
du monde quand même capable en kaki elle
est noire et qu'il a donc
veillez de conduire gagne cette partie
grâce à une superbe combinaison basé sur
le maître du couloir alors capablanca
champion du monde dans les années 20 je
crois qu'en 1927 donc josé rallu
capablanca champion du monde
donc cubant qui a été le troisième
champion du monde de l'histoire des
échecs depuis que la fédération existe
juste après la sq air et avant un
liquide voilà donc et le premier étant
steinitz grand steinitz
voilà donc là dans cette position donc
capable ans qui en échange les pièces
pour l'instant tout est classique c'est
son truc à lui les simplifications
il adore ça donc il simplifie encore et
là donc il a créé donc ce qu'on appelle
un clou un couloir il a créé donc un
couloir sur cette grande première rangée
on voit que le roi ne peut pas fuir sur
ces cases là oui on peut pas s'enfuir
donc là il yaa il ya un très très long
couloir dans cette position donc tu
pourrais me poser de questions
intéressant dans cette position s'était
fans
je pourrais te poses des questions
intéressant en fait j'étais en train de
réfléchir je ne voyais pas c'est un peu
con bien souvent effectivement comment
en profiter puisque pour l'instant quand
même par exemple la touriste il ne peut
pas venir la cause de la dame qui
protège et au vox il en échec ici
peut-être la dame peut venir en défense
alors c'est vrai c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué que ça puisque si un échec ici
la dame revient en défense on est obligé
en façon il n'y a pas le choix elle va
pas bien ici sinon sinon la dame noire
la prendrai tout simplement un coup oui
tout à fait donc la noire revient les
dames la dame blanche brogniart défense
sur la case et femmes est la grande
question pourquoi ne pas doubler les
tours donc de doubler la tour avec la
dame est attaqué la dame
et voilà il avait scellé le match du
couloir voilà mais là mais là je me dis
l'attention contre nantes contre eux
battent contre moi d'accord tout à fait
contre attaque alors un contrat contre
attaque qui seraient situés ou sur sur
quelle zone de l'échiquier elle voit je
vois que j'ai la même chose en face
comment voit ici il est bloqué aussi et
que cet homme-là est bien elle est tout
à fait disponible pour plutôt que de me
concentrer sur la défense
pourquoi pas assaini moi même du coup
voilà donc là dans cette position le
coût 2 le fameux coup de massue de
massue donc tour c8 qui inversent la
tendance est maintenant c'est le roi
noir qui va se faire mater on est obligé
de rendre la tour du typhon c'est une
catastrophe on aime bien se fait mater
ouais mais bon on a quand même un
champion du monde il a vu comment il a
vu beaucoup plus loin moi je suis comme
je suis pas champion du monde tu va
montrer alors je vais te montrer
donc on va revenir à la position
initiale donc c'était celle ci on va un
petit peu enlevé toutes ses flèches
comme ça qu'on veut éclaircir la
position oui et là donc on voit que dans
cette position on ne peut pas donc
descendre la dérive directement sur
cette case là donc il va falloir qu'on
peut tenter une seconde ap peut-être
jean-luc une déviation
il va falloir porter quelque chose d'un
peu extraordinaire tout à fait les
déviations en ce moment peut dévier les
pièces et c'est là que j'ai compris la
manoeuvre saviez pas ce que fait
réfléchir un peu voilà ce que tu es
malade tu me l'a pas montré avant n'en
jetez pas montré avant mais il faut
quand même que tu travailles la position
phare et des échecs
alors effectivement alors c'est un peu
aussi une combinaison qui basé selon le
couloir donc on voit que cette menace
possible et en fait on va donc jouer ce
qu'on appelle une déviation une attaque
double en tenant compte de cette menace
de maths et je pense que beaucoup
jean-luc ces dames ici les deux
puisqu'on atteint la tour on attaque la
dame et on voit que cette double attaque
et mortel parce que si les blancs
prennent ici elles nadia mat
voilà du couloir juste une précision
stéphane donc un truc important pour les
internautes
c'est que dans cette position prendre la
dame avec la dame henry 2 c'est ce qu'on
appelle la déviation puisque la dame en
vue de contrôler la casse d un contre la
casse de dates de la tour en venant sur
la case b2 la dame
drôle plus 7 15 b 1 d un plateau peut
très bien venir ici c'est ce qu'on
appelle la déviation
voilà donc après john b 2 plusieurs
choix on pouvait peut-être essayer de
défendre la date de cette manière où est
toujours contrôlé la case la case d un
mail à la dame bien sûr la casbah en
effet à créer chaque roi voilà
et si la dame dessin d'une case
maintenant eh bien c'est un peu
différent tout à l'heure parce que la
tour tout à l'heure n'était pas en prise
voilà la tour est descendu d'une case
est donc là on peut très simplement
mangé la tour donc prendre la tour sur
la caf c2 et on se retrouve avec une
tour de plus une tour de plus et plus
que sage en lui parce qu'on est blanc
comme il ya un mode de couleurs
possibles encore les blancs peuvent pas
empêcher au prochain coup tours b1 qui
prendra la dame
voilà donc après si on se réfère
maintenant on met élémentaire après la
bataille avec une dame ou une tour de
plus voilà exane est beaucoup plus
simple ou alors on va juste revoir cette
position là il ya un dernier coup qui a
l'air de tenir c'est le ku'damm e1 le
coup de main de la dame défend la tour
en c3 et défendent la case d un ouais
mais on peut pas défendre deux choses en
même temps et voilà d'autres là il va
encore y avoir cette fameuse ce fait le
sacrifice de déviation donc déviée la
dame de la case des 1 en prenant la tour
sur ces 3 voilà et l'a donc si la dame
prend elle ne contrôle plus les cases
des uns et la tour peut venir ici faire
un échec et mat le fameux couloir
toujours encore très important la dame
doit se sacrifier et on essaie maths et
s'évade
donc voilà après dan b2 finalement pour
la petite histoire
il faut tout simplement dire qu'après le
coup d'un bep 2 les les blancs abandonné
puisque quand même face à un champion du
monde il n'y avait pas trop trop
d'autres possibilités oui il y aura avec
la tour de plus c'est un jeu d'enfant et
puis on peut voir un angle si on joue un
coup comme dame-là d'année un dernier
exemple c'est très simple on va y aller
tout de suite ont fait échec
on doit donner la dame on prend la dame
le roi prend et on prend la tour voilà
je pense qu'avec une dame de plus je
veux être facile ça m'a très facile en
coin on va voir on va faire une cure et
de pions puis enfin on fait ce qu'on
veut
il ya même plus de réflexion d'accord
donc ça c'était un autre exemple je
crois qu'on a d'autres exemples en
réserve à la fin mais du coup on va voir
d'autres exemples toujours le même
principe trouvé la clé dont qui permet
d'obtenir ce schéma tactique élémentaire
on va dire donc la clé quelquefois là
elle était un petit peu et est basé sur
des échanges dans l'exemple qui suit
donc on va voir que la clé et elle est
basée plutôt sur un sacrifice
alors là le couloir est assez obscure on
va dire que là le couloir c'est quoi le
couloir des noirs on va dire que le
couloir on peut l'imaginer donc comme
d'habitude le couloir c'est ça le roi et
là c'est toujours ça puisque le roi est
là mais il est quand même bien protégés
ce couloir puisqu'on voit quand même que
sur la case donc sur la case envers les
hyènes tour oui donc la tour qui est
quand même censé être la pièce une des
pièces principales pour défendre les
couloirs tout à fait donc là une grande
question se pose
comment crée donc une véritable menace
sur la huitième rang j'ai alors à noter
quand même avant d'arriver sur la
possibilité c'est aussi le fait que le
fou ici vous le rôle d'un pion oui et
donc c'est lui qui complète le couloir
malgré le couple de petites saynètes qui
a été créée il ya quand même la pièce
qui gêne et si ça a été un cavalier ici
c'était moins clair parce que le
cavaliere aurait pu venir en défense
d'un matin ici alors que le fouillis des
beaux arts le flou ne peut pas voilà
donc dans cette position il va falloir
trouver quelque chose de vraiment
spectaculaire pour créer un couloir bon
alors quelle est la pièce qui va qui va
faire le fameux maître du couloir
deux possibilités soit c'est la tour qui
va éventuellement se placer sur cette
case puisqu'elle est sur sa ligne droite
et elle est directement placée sur le
couloir mais un écho au moment où pas
trop comment pour l'instant on va pas
trop comment soit c'est c'est la table
c'est la dame donc qui va qui va essayer
de se placer là non plus on veut pas
trop comment la tour qui gêne donc il ya
l'attenté j'avais alors maintenant je
vais donner un petit avis c'est que
cette position
c'est donc c'est le maître du couloir
mais c'est aussi un matt qui ne fait que
trois coups c'est à dire que dans cette
position tu as trois coups pour mater
donc il faut vraiment que tu fasses
quelque chose d'incroyable pour ça c'est
pas ça c'est un gros indice général
quant à elle est effectivement les
problèmes des chèques etc concerne trois
coups en général il faut chercher les
échec parce que l'échec c'est ce qui
force des resserre à jouer des coûts en
général y en a pas des mille et donc les
échecs sont efforcés qui permettent de
calculer très vite des variantes
puisqu'en général n'y a pas beaucoup tes
fins sur un échec
souvent même des fois qu'une seule
défense et parfois il y en a une deux ou
trois mais pas plus donc c'est les
suites les plus faciles à voir
la première méthode quand vous mêmes
problèmes d'échec à résoudre on met le
premier dans une partie on vous dit pas
que vous
ma tante rock ou en face c'est un
problème toujours gardé les échecs et y
compris les échecs sur sacrifices les
achète son sacrifice où il faut faire
attention aux coups quand on quand on
vous dit il ya maintenant trois coups
pour résoudre le problème il faut
chercher toutes les solutions humaines
des solutions les plus inhabituels pour
il ne faut pas hésiter à aller voir les
choses curieuses donc là dans cette
position donc maintenant on va passer à
la solution dans cette position il faut
prendre la tour avec la dame
voilà donc sacrifice de dames sacrifice
de dames mais première chose logique on
élimine quand même la pièce qui défend
le gaulois qui défendent donc la pièce
est éliminé là l'adversaire avec les
noirs a abandonné on va vous expliquer
pourquoi il est abandonné
évidemment il obligé pour la dame et là
on glisse un échec avec le cavalier donc
le cavalier qui est sûre la casser cette
attaque le roi est très important c'est
que la tour d un empêche le roi noir de
s'échapper
voilà toutes les cases sont contrôlés
par la tour donc la toque et sur la case
d1 on voit que toute cette colonne des
contrôles et donc le roi doit revenir
sur la case f8
hélas si si vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est le fameux maître du couloir
donc on va reprendre là on a un couloir
donc le maître du couloir s'obtient
après le coutour des 8es fait qu'il est
là on a le fameux match du couloir donc
un bel exemple qui est basé sur un
sacrifice dame et qui conduit et de
manière inévitable mètres de couloirs
voilà très joli très jolie combinaison
avec matt du couloir finale c'est très
important de
du coup c'est là qu'on comprend qu
effectivement plus on connaît les choses
simples final on a vu
ici le mât du couloir dans cette cette
leçon du jour est bien plus après dans
la partie on peut faire des combinaisons
complexes
qu'est-ce qu'on va se retrouver après
l'inclusion qu'on sait qu'on sait
traiter en tête et on remonte concert la
complexité c'est à dire qu'après si on
sait traiter le simple on va gérer des
choses un peu plus complexe pour nous
ramener aux simples qu'on sait traiter
et comme ça on monte en complexité et on
arrive appris à trouver des combines une
très très bonne écoute champion du monde
zdenek au champion du monde des coûts
très élaboré la bon donc ça c'est des
coups de grands maîtres
c'est un des plus grands maîtres
prochain exemple donc encore un coup de
grands maîtres donc le grand maître qui
a les noirs là sept foyers qui gagnent
donc là c'est un petit peu le même
principe que la partie ii capable en cas
c'est à dire c'est ce qu'on appelle une
déviation
donc ça c'est une combinaison qui est
basée sur la déviation des vies une
pièce pour faire un maître du couloir
alors c'est les noirs qui gagne dans
cette position on voit que le roi blanc
et encore une fois placé dans un couloir
la salle couloir plus étroits puisque
c'est que le gaz
voilà mais comme il est sur la pente
c'est normal donc ça veut dire quand
même paris peut pas aller évidemment le
roi peut pas rester à gaza peut pas les
soirs sur la case de ibos joli ça veut
dire qu effectivement avec cette notion
du mode du couloir du coup quand on va
se retrouver face à des positions comme
ça il faut que ça devienne l'instinct du
joueur d'échecs l'instinct de voir tout
de suite que le roi adverse est en
position est du couloir et donc
d'analyser les possibilités de maths qui
s'en suivent tout à fait alors donc
si donc je propose cette position à un
élève sa position comme dirait son look
ou instinctif qui va me proposer va être
dans cette position stéphane ça paraît
logique et jean-luc il ya une
combinaison qui gagne tout de suite si
je ne réfléchis pas plus que ça j'ai ici
donc le bas du couloir quand tu viens de
l'indiquer et j'ai deux pièces lourdes
ici donc je peux faire un échec ici et
en cas de prise de la tour je reprends
la remballe montrer tout de suite
peut-être qu'on va le jouer on va le
jouer dans cette position oui tout à
fait les lèvres mais proposerait le coup
de main donc on va regarder ce coup
alors attendre d'être à son adaptation
qui qui fait échec au roi voilà et qui
donc qui sacrifie la dame puisque la
tour va manger la dame donc la tour
prend la dame sur la tour reprend la
dame se donne et là on fait le mec de
couleur lorsque tu as bien ce que tu as
bien vu ce que mon élève à me proposer
mais je vais lui trouver une parade va
revoir le roi et mat
oui on voit le match j'avais trouvé une
parade c'est que son dernier échec je
vais lui dire c'est un joli coup mais
malheureusement je défends mon couloir
pardalets fin voilà est là donc on voit
que le pouvoir est bien protégé par les
sourdes et on veut que les pièces
courtes se défendre mutuellement malgré
le fait que la dame soit au milieu
exact ça c'est quelque chose à bien
connaître aussi oui donc si par exemple
il y prend madame la tour qui est là bas
va reprendre la dame et j'espère qu'il
est pour l'instant c'est loin d'être
gagné
les noirs d'autant plus que si l'on
regarde la position de façon plus
générale il ya quand même gros pions
passé ici avec donc un avantage blanc de
toute façon voilà position puisque ce
pion et avant une grosse menace pour les
noirs et en plus il est central donc il
pose d'énormes problèmes
donc on va revenir à la position de base
donc la position initiale donc avec la
tour ont un petit peu réfléchi tout ça
donc ça ne marche pas voilà donc j'aurai
flèche
ça ne marche pas dans cette position il
faut donc chercher une solution un peu
alternative c'est-à-dire cas dans cette
position il faut trouver une combine qui
enlève on enlève cette tour de la
première rangée
alors je croise alors voilà je crois que
la meilleure
non mais la combine est introuvable si
on n'est pas un grand tacticien
je crois que c'est vraiment beaucoup
qu'il faut soit être un ordinateur pour
le voir tout de suite soit grands
champions sont un grand champion c'est
vraiment le coup c'est bronstein rouge
times qui éblouissent couleurs sont
projetés dans mon propre style qui a été
un finaliste du championnat du monde
oui qui avait joué le tournant du
candidat no sur x et si oui et puis qui
est donc qui a été donc finalement
vice-champion du monde en 1950 consent
bloc et qui dans cette position a joué
un coup incroyable
il donne sa tour alors loin de la tour
donc la tour le coup d'envoi un gros
bond avec la limite jusqu'à la case à
trois et il n'y a qu'une fois que ce
coup est joué qu'on comprend
à quoi il sert parce que sinon voilà
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle une
déviation
on va expliquer pourquoi puisque si la
tour prend la tour est dévié de cette
première rangée et là il ya le mode du
couloir et là il ya le fameux maître du
couloir il faut défendre avec la donne
est ce qu'on doit remettre la dame est
là mais elle a tourné plus sur béziers
dont il peut tout simplement mater les
sens et c'est comme moi c'est là qu'on
voit que tout les prix sont pas
rassemblées en fait voilà et dernière
dernières bondir la dernière possibilité
c'est de prendre avec le pion aux éclats
d'âme ou avec la dame
alors oui c'est notre possibilité ses
gongs donc on va boire d'abord voir la
prise du pion si on prend du plomb cette
fois la dame prend la tour et voilà
c'est tout simplement
et si on prend avec la dame cette fois
c'est pas la tour qui est déviée mais
c'est la dame puisque tout à l'heure on
avait dit qu'après tam échec
il y avait d'un f1 ont ramené la dame
sur iphone mais la dame maintenant elle
aura trois là ne peut pas venir sur la
réforme
c'est un très joli conte donc on doit
prendre la dame la tour reprend et ses
nattes très très joli ce qui veut dire
qu'après tour à 3 la dernière
possibilité c'est d'enlever la tour donc
la mecque là par exemple mais la safer à
sa peur tout de suite vers très
facilement à cause de tout reprendre la
route vers la dame et après c'est un jeu
d'enfant pour les murs de gagner cette
partie
évidemment le la menace de maths du
pouvoir gagne pas immédiatement il ya
pas match immédiat qui est toujours
dédié souvent des défenses d'ailleurs
mais les défenses perdre tellement de
matériel que la menace a suffi à a gagné
la partie pour toi là donc c'est une
menace grave et omniprésente même à haut
niveau
alors donc on va juste voir maintenant
le dernier exemple tu as fait donc le
dernier exemple qui est un petit peu un
petit peu on va un petit peu accéléré là
tout le monde a compris qu'il faut jouer
tours 8
ouais parce que c'est le vin de couleur
classique voilà donc c'est le match des
couleurs classiques sa moyenne une
défense bien couloir mais on va essayer
de
on colmate avec le cahier fuite on va
comme était donc le couloir alors là bon
je vais donner un petit coup de pouce
au spectateur c'est que je vais leur
simplement leur proposer ce petit coup
de cavaliers donc là c'est le petit coup
de pouce échec
c'est un petit coup de pouce de
diagonale donc on donne un échec de la
leçon et on voit bien que si le roi
vient sur la case à chocs 8
là il ya le fameux match du couloir avec
la tour de caen même demain on voit
qu'il ya une attaque imparable sur le
ring je me dis attention aujourd'hui que
je prends de la dame a donc la vallée de
la dore alors que je suis protégé par
mon pions oui le pion peuvent apprendre
le cavalier puisqu'il est cloué par la
dame dont la dame qui fait échec au roi
dans ces cas-là tout à fait donc on doit
attendre la fin de la dame tu prends la
table et là donc dans ceux déjà
longtemps parce que j'ai une pièce de
plus tout à fait donc là dans ce dernier
exemple je vais montrer donc à une
petite astuce c'est que j'ai montré pour
la semble que des exemples de ma des
couloirs avec la tour la sermat du
couloir un peu particulier puisque c'est
avec la dame
d'accord j'ai tout dit je crois puisque
c'est maintenant de coup ci c'est avec
la dame mais que fait donc ça veut dire
qu'il reste là bas la fin pour mater le
roi noir maintenant ses fans qu'est-ce
qu'il va falloir faire
eh bien on va en trouver ce qu'on a vu
dans le deuxième exemple je crois donc
il faut éliminer la pièce qui empêche
qui empêche le mode du couloir le plan
c'est le cavalier voilà donc le cavalier
en fuite qui est la pièce gênante de la
position donc on
on flingue lecavalier ne faut pas avoir
peur
faut pas avoir peur faut pas lésiner
donc sur les moyens on a déjà donné une
pièce on peut donner une tour c'est
encore plus jolie donc la tour prend le
cavalier donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un
sacrifice de qualité puisque on sacrifie
une tour contre un cavalier leroy
reprend la tour et là il ya matin le
coup donc afin de mettre du couloir mais
c'est pas vraiment un couloir habituel
puisque on voit qu'il ya une caisse de
fuissé and me couvrant sa à 2000 couloir
voilà c'est un corridor soir à corridor
c'est mais bon on va pas pour tout de
suite on l'attend si dame la dame des
vite donc d'un v8 qui attaquent le roi
et qui contrôle la seule classe de fuite
soit d'avoir davantage de la dame sait
qu'elles contrôlent aussi les 15 ans
diagonale et donc il ya quand même matt
sonic ou world parce que on découvre
qu'en général quand le roi est enfermé
par ses propres pièces mais c'est vrai
que là c'est quasiment pareil c'est ses
deux pions qui font office de maths et
là c'est la dame par contre qui complète
le petit couloir où il se met couloir
donc c'est une rolls de la dame à la
dame elle joue en diagonale la tour on
ne joue qu'en ligne droite la tour fait
des vrais couloir la dame peut faire des
semis couloir donc je crois qu'on a on a
vu tous les exemples sont les exemples
très joli très joli plan tactique
aujourd'hui sur son nom du couloir donc
très important comprendre le principe
évidemment et du coup mais quand vous
êtes face à un roi qui est dans une
position d'eva du pouvoir et bien
toujours avoir un oeil sur les
combinaisons tactiques
ça peut ça peut arriver ça arrive
souvent ça on peut pas dire que ça soit
passons dans les menaces de ma du
couloir se sont pas directement
décisives en plus comme on l'a vu tout à
leur permettent de gagner énormément de
matériel comme comme la dame comme
le world peur et donc permettre de
gagner aussi la partie à plus long terme
voilà et bien terminée pour cette leçon
très complète je crois aujourd'hui oui
sur le mât du couserans espère que les
internautes pour faire beaucoup de
progrès donc dans la phase tactique les
diagonales des échos note voilà tout
à bientôt